[Music]
hi everyone this feels more closer than
home to home than you guys think it'd
probably sit on that desk over there so
it's very very close but it's wonderful
wonderful to be here
my name is Gorgon I am originally from a
very small country called Macedonia how
many of you have heard of Macedonia
right oh thank god
okay how many of you have been to
Macedonia why would you do that to
yourself sighs it's a wonderful country
now it's a wonderful country the after
this talk I'll convince you otherwise
but still wonderful so for those of you
who've been there that you might see
some some of this familiar because when
I was 15 a young young little guy during
our cold and kind of groggy crappy
winners in Macedonia I wasn't allowed to
leave any windows or doors of my house
open and the reason because we weren't
afraid to let the heat escape it was
more because we didn't want to let in
the so-called smelly fog now for those
of you who haven't been to Macedonia or
at least during the winter here's the
here's a picture of sculpey on my home
city and I can assure you that the city
is there you just can't really see it
because of the smelly fog when I used to
ask my parents about it what they would
say is you know what this happens every
winter spring will come this will all go
away so really don't put too much
thought into it and I didn't until four
years ago when a pile of seemingly
unimportant data would change my life to
transform my country now the key word
there was data we're we're at a data
conference everyone loves data and in
this day and age of technology we create
and collect data at an enormous pace I'm
sure all of you know IBM they ran a
study which they found that yearly daily
sorry we create 2.5 quantity
in bytes of data to transform that into
layman's terms that's 40 million copies
of Wikipedia written daily huge amount
of data some of this is available to us
the mere mortals the public through
either online or offline open datasets
for example here in the Netherlands the
Ministry of Internal Affairs offers
13,000 of these open data sets on
ranging topics from politics to culture
to health to the economy everything you
can imagine is there and this is a huge
amount of data but then the question
becomes are we really putting it to good
use and being a board 21 year old
college student back home forced to stay
indoors during winter because of the
smelly fog I was searching for my next
project to do as I was looking up online
I stumbled upon a little government
website which featured these local open
datasets and as I riffle through the
titles one caught my eye in particular
air pollution data set now being the
geek that I am I quickly download this
data and I wrote a little algorithm
which would analyze and kind of tell me
what what what's there what is what is
it trying to hide because it was in a
garbled JSON format
but I had a problem with with this
algorithm I had a bug I can't couldn't
get rid of it because it was Contin to
giving me unrealistic numbers I mean it
was telling me that air pollution in
Macedonia was 20 times or really you
limit I mean it was four times over
Beijing I mean come on it's it's it's
ridiculous it's it's unrealistic it's it
was true my country was suffocating at
the hands of an invisible enemy all that
smelly fog that was smog but
at this point the data was out there was
public so where are the new stories
where are people on social media where
are protesters on the streets silence
what I learned that day was very logical
when I think about it but also very
powerful the data it was out there and
it was telling horrific story but
because it was being presented in such a
complex and incomprehensible way for the
average user
it wasn't adding any value on the
contrary it was just being overlooked I
couldn't stand by and watch this happen
to my country I took it upon myself to
find out a way of presenting this raw
data which is already existing in a
readable and understandable way to the
general public so it gets its message
across my solution to the problem was my
voice or my air a web and mobile app
which simply takes this raw data and
with the help of visualizations charts
graphs and colors displays it to the
average user and tries to inform them of
the situation that is going on in my own
country I published this app and one
month later the results were were
amazing more than 1 million people had
access to this data either through the
to mobile apps the web app or simply by
watching the news which was finally
starting to pick up on the subject
people were shocked naturally people
were outraged some even said I was lying
we had the then Minister of ecology go
on TV and say you know what don't trust
Gordian don't trust my voice look he's
lying he's being paid by the Americans
and by Soros to spread lies like you
know angry little child tantrum I didn't
even know about this I get a call from a
reporter saying hey do you want to give
a counter statement as to what explains
what happened sure oh I'll give a
counter statement so I go back and I say
all right Minister I'll I'll give you an
idea how about you and me sit down in
front of the media I'll open my app and
you can open your government website
and we'll compare the data if the data
differs I'll shut down the Apple burn
all the code I've written I'll throw the
servers out the windows but if the data
is the same then you resign
guess who was never heard from again I
mean when you don't know what you're
talking about
at this point Macedonia is not such an
amazing country and they could have gone
down the kind of corrupt government path
that we had at that point and locked me
up for whatever false accusations but
the problem was this data was out there
it was public on their own servers so by
them locking up the messenger they
weren't going to stop what was about to
happen the next winter people were
outraged by the government's
unwillingness to do anything about this
problem what we did is we took to the
streets of five biggest cities in
Macedonia protesting trying to raise
awareness among our people that this is
a huge problem
even better oh by the way this was like
five seconds before I started throwing
eggs at the government they really
questioned well I don't know why they
don't like me
it wasn't even it was not only us we
even had politicians in Parliament
waving around screen shots of the app
trying to convince their own colleagues
that this is no longer a political issue
nor is it the gender nor is it a racial
issue because what unites us all in this
is that we all breathe the same here
there's there's no escape from it at one
point we had scientists come down from
Sweden and run analysis on the pollution
data and the effects that was having on
public health and what they came up with
was this number 3000 yearly premature
deaths directly attributed to air
pollution 3,000 of my fellow citizens
3,000 of my friends and 3,000 of my
family
let me ask you all a question especially
for those of you who are from the
Netherlands but this goes to everyone
how many of you have opened your phones
this week and check the weather to
understand your skin right now settle
with the raise of hands how many of you
have done this exactly CLE please keep
your hands up and look around you
imagine that all of you here are living
in Macedonia and instead of keeping your
hands up for checking the weather on
your phone you're trying to understand
if the air outside is even safe to leave
your homes let that sink in Macedonia
may be far in the east of Europe and our
problem may be far greater but you
countries like the Netherlands aren't
out of the woods either just last year
the courts ruled that the Dutch state
must find more ways of getting clean air
because if nothing's done
it'll take way until 2030 before the EU
set goals for clean air are reached by
the Netherlands and until then the
European environmental agency estimates
that more than 11,000 people will
prematurely die every year directly
attributed to air pollution from the
roadways households and from the
industry but it's not all that dark
because we live in a day and age of
technology and we have access to all
this data we as citizens are now more
than ever empowered to act by utilising
open datasets like the one I used in
Macedonia we are now able to run our own
analysis come up with our own
conclusions and lobby for changes all by
ourselves and we don't even have to let
the sky be the limit I cross this
barrier and I'm now working together
with data from the European Space Agency
to analyze satellite pollution data and
pinpoint exactly from sources on the
ground which ground sensors can't pick
up a funny story one of these pollutant
sources was recently discovered in my
home city
a medical trash incinerator the problem
it was donated to Macedonia by the UK in
2001 and if we're to set up this exact
medical trash incinerator within the EU
it would be legal to operate it
because of its high emission levels we
were very surprised because the Guardian
caught on to this back in 2001 and no
one really said anything and it was only
recently discovered by using satellite
data it's it's sad to see this but it
also gives me hope because we were able
to protest our way of forcing the
government to put correct filters on
this facility and lower its impact that
it has on our lives this was kind of my
story and what happened in my country
but what I ask from you guys because you
all love data yet that one of the
reasons why you're here go online and
look at all this open data that's
already available out there see what
catches your eye what triggers your
interest and spend some time in
analyzing it because I will guarantee
you that every single open data set out
there hide secrets waiting for
adventures like you guys to discover
them as for me there will be two things
happening one we've had great success in
Macedonia with the air app we've really
awoken the people we've tackled three
points of not only informing but
educating and empowering people to act
and since we're not the only country
fighting this problem we're planning to
now expand this is the first time ever I
show screen shots in public the air app
is coming to the Netherlands we are
coming here
they yep this will be just the start of
our journey where we tried to fight for
more clean air because I honestly
believe that clean air is a human right
and the second thing this winter apart
from pushing the movement here in the
Netherlands I will be back on the
streets in Macedonia
shoulder-to-shoulder with 3,000 of my
fellow activists continuing to fight a
war against an invisible enemy there has
been progress but there's still a long
way to go until we can literally breathe
that ease and data is the pathway
that'll take us there
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is why we like data activism
talks so we still have a large amount of
time for questions before lunch
I'll start the first person why did the
government open access to that data set
in the first place
very good question so we have 17
measuring stations in Macedonian they
were all donated by the EU so the
government had to put them online like
it or not and what they did initially
when placing them they had only one
source of information which was a
billboard in the center of the city
which we can't tell you how polluted it
is and when people first realized this
the the problem severity of the problem
they started movements and protests and
then that billboard went into repairs
seven years we're still repairing that
billboard so the government wasn't
really fond but they had to because this
was a donation from the U and since we
are none a non-eu country it's one of
the requirements that we have to get
membership steps so they were kind of
forced which was good for the people can
you tell us something about how you got
the first app out and especially in how
you got it
popular right so the app wasn't even
meant to go not viral but just just to
be out there it was a project I was
learning Android this is my first
Android app so I was learning how to
code and I thought oh this this
information would be useful to show at
least to my friends and kind of informed
on what's going on so it was social
media that yaniv took it off it was
worth toward me word to mouth
communication it was definitely not a
marketing campaign because we posted it
out there and people could see the
pollution outside there were aware that
pollution was there there were not aware
how bad it is and by having access to
this app people started panicking of
course what happened was it spread
through social media by the use of maybe
I can show you I'm not sure that our
screenshot here has that so we have the
circle which kind of fills up the as bad
the worse the air gets and this circle
during winter Macedonia is full red all
time full red circle and that full red
circle became a symbol of this app so
people started putting a full red circle
on their profile pictures around their
face saying hey it's really really bad
so it was social media and and just
because of the social impact of the app
that it started spreading around of
course after that we partnered up with
organizations in Macedonia that also
fight this problem and help spread the
app further but uh it was it was word to
mouth communication I can imagine you're
not the oh you might you're not the only
person doing this sort of data activism
I mean I can imagine that you may have
spoken to several other people that are
doing similar things what are some of
the other sort of more inspirational
things that people might need to look at
when they're looking for more things
like this I think there's there's
there's a lot there's a lot so
definitely first of all Macedonia isn't
the only country facing a problem like
this second of all there's a lot of
stuff people can do with activism one
thing that's going on for example now in
Macedonia which I really like there's a
political counter which I'm also
involved in we took all the promises
from the mayor of my city of the capital
city of Macedonia we put them really
nice sheet online and a really nice
website which kind of explains
everything and then we put a counter how
long have you been in office versus how
long have you actually fulfilled all
these things have what have you
fulfilled from all these promises which
again takes data presented more clearly
to people and tells them hey promises
are one but have they actually done
anything about about this so there's a
lot of examples online of people doing
this and countries like China for
example which also is battling this
India's battling pollution like this and
I was surprised to see that Europe is
also not not that the cleanest of places
so there's a lot of data out there all
you guys need to do just go online see
what your country's data offers and have
some fun with it because believe me
either from a very sad and kind of dark
cause like this we were able to change
people's lives hopefully for the better
in the long run
any other questions all the way in the
back
for sure please repeat the question for
the audio right so is there any way that
you can contribute to the air app in the
Netherlands and help out for sure so the
air app is run kind of by me and I have
one of my friends that's that's helping
out with with coding so it's kind of a
one and a Half Men endeavor so we
definitely need all the help that we can
get it's it's a market that I've been
living here for three years now so I
don't know it's that well yes and any
help from from local NGOs from local
people from anyone just to spread the
word to help us out understand what is
the more local issues that are causing
air pollution here and to help us fight
this cause better is more than
appreciated if anyone has any ideas
please come talk to me in the break and
I'm more than happy to to partner up and
engage in this because I think it's a
it's a it's a critical battle that that
should be fought we've got large
widespread publicity around this back in
Macedonia what kind of outcomes are
happening now and hopefully over the
next couple of years right so initially
this app launched when we had an older
government which didn't like this idea
at all so it was kind of pushed down
people were saying it was it was a lie
we had a change of government which one
of their election promises was they're
going to do something about the air
I'm annoyed to say that that was just
another government promise that's not
really being fulfilled as much as they
can say we've planted ten trees I'm like
wow good job guys you've saved the world
now they've done stuff they've done
they've forced this this medical trash
incinerator to have better filters on
them which was kind of one of the major
causes they're looking into ideas of
subsidizing pellets that you can kind of
burn instead of burning wood which is
one of the major causes in Macedonia for
pollution that you can do more stuff
like that so P it's slowly coming
together but I think that it's just I
think it's
I think in the end it's people pressure
which will which will make this change
and once we get satellite data we're
able to pinpoint stuff exactly where
that's going on there's no more hiding
from ground sensors which data could be
also possibly polluted by because it's
in government control so it's always
scarier what what is going on with that
data but I think slowly there's change
and the more pressure and the more
publicity there that you apply to this
topic the more chances are that the
government will actually start to act on
it why is so polluted why isn't the
other Balkan states as they are I'm
sorry to say they are I've looked into
the data of majority of Balkan states we
are all facing the same issues a lot of
the Balkan states aren't in the EU so
we're not following all these
legislations and laws that they should
have been there for for clean
environment all the cars that are banned
in the EU we import them all the trash
that's banned to be burned in the EU we
buy it and burn it for some reason I
don't know why we think that's a good
business model it's it's a combination
of again no laws for environment stuff
and a natural phenomenon that occurs
during winter so this picture here this
is part of the natural phenomenon it's
called temperature inversion so what you
have is hot air from the ground rising
from heating sources you've got cold air
because it's winter and they create kind
of a lid on top Macedonia is surrounded
by mountains which doesn't allow air
flow to go through so you have all the
pollution that's building up it's just
staying down there underneath visting
and that's that's it's it's not only our
country that that's fighting this
problem so hopefully we'll able will be
able to spread this app around other
countries as well in the Balkans and
kind of say hey guys I'm sorry but it's
not only us we all need to kind of lead
a fight into this it was kind of sad
this is so this is my home city and
there's a little there's a little
Mountain over there that the kind of
overlooks the city on the mountain we
have a cross like the Millennium cross
on top so what we joke about is where
this is like a cemetery they put a cross
on top and they buried the
country so we're with we have very dark
humor because that's all that's left to
do and we even have a gondola that takes
you up to the cross and we call it
stairway to heaven because you kind of
you you literally can go through the
pollution out into clear in the open
clear skies and it that's just a surreal
feeling but but yeah it's not just us
and hopefully we'll be able to get more
people involved because it's a terrible
thing then maybe a final question to
help get people motivated this is a
picture and it's obviously bad but let's
look at our own country then how bad is
it here I mean I just saw a demo of the
app and I can imagine that we're
supposed to be adhering to some
standards and there's a bit more laws
and stuff how worried should we be we
live in the center of Amsterdam probably
the cleanest there in the world right
well off topic no so so the Netherlands
is definitely far better than what
Macedonia is we in winter walk around
with masks so this is this is much
better but honestly I was surprised that
as I was looking at the data is judging
by the no amount of bikes here in the
rain and the wind you would expect it to
be very clean but apparently it's not
that good so the Netherlands is hovering
around the top limit that the U has set
on what what's acceptable with pollution
and the Netherlands hovering around the
top limit sometimes it'll be break a bit
more of course not 20 times but still
it'll be there so the problem is if
nothing's done then this actually may
even break over the top limit of what is
allowed as safe pollution in in cities
around around the EU so that's one of
the ideas that we aim to show with this
app is we believe that it's pretty clean
outside but even this amount of
pollution which is hovering on the top
limit may cause health effects to people
here and it can cause some sort of
social pressure to put on these sources
of pollution to get rid of it so I'm
more than more than happy because I live
here now for three years and I'm part of
this I feel part of this community I
would be more than happy to spread this
message across and say hey guys I'm here
I really want to help out and work with
work with you to to even make better and
greener environment it make kind of the
Netherlands a very very green place that
is that it is supposed to be in in the
first place and just to be clear so the
the European standard that we're
supposed to
where if I were to say in the middle of
am son we're just probably one of the
the dirtier places to be
that's not exceeding the limit or is it
that we average the entire country and
say well we take the entire green speck
we average that without stir them no so
there's no no definitely not so I'm sure
Tom has quite a quite a few measuring
stations and the Netherlands in general
I think has over 100 so that's very good
because you've got a lot of data points
that you can compare and you can
definitely see hotspots Amsterdam is not
one of them which is which is lucky you
got Rotterdam with the ports you got
some of the sea sides as well you can
really see concentration of pollution
happening there or areas where you have
a lot of factories kind of outside of
the cities as well but just just to be a
give you an example so the limit is 50
micrograms per meter square of pm10 none
of us just imagine the number 50 the
Netherlands is at around 40 50 to 50 in
that range and it hovers Amsterdam at
least hovers around that aid Macedonia
is in the thousands so yeah that's why I
thought it was a bug unfortunately it's
not so yes there there's Amsterdam is
not bad for sure but it could be
improved please give a great
[Applause]